so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
do
out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
two
[Music]
two
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
do
hey everyone good morning and welcome to
another day of games let's play for all
today it is the xbox
first party showcase very very excited
uh we last saw um a showcase from xbox
back in may
which thanks to current events feels
like it was maybe three years ago
but today we're going to be focusing on
the first party titles we're very
excited
joining me this morning are michael hyam
who what up hi everyone and to
he's saying x gonna give it here
i mean i already did uh like xbox xbox
to the tune of sex bomb
by tom jones now we've got x going with
you we're gonna be running through all
of the xbox puns we possibly can today
before the show starts we have about 29
minutes
until we get to see some of the lovely
first party titles from xbox
we're going to be here discussing what
we hope what we dream is going to be a
part of the show and make some educated
guesses
on what we definitely know is gonna be
in the show obviously the big one
halo but we'll talk about that in a
little bit tam i'm gonna come to you
first
we know that this is a game focused
showcase are we expecting anything at
all
um about pricing about the so rumored
xbox
series s model or do you think they're
gonna solely keep it focused on the
games and not have any surprises for us
at all
i think after the the last um uh
showcase that they had where they
promised you know third-party gameplay
and kind of
biffed it in a lot of ways i think
they've been more clear about the
messaging
and um i think they're gonna want to be
a little more strict about sticking to
that messaging and not catching anyone
off guard
um so i don't think we'll get any
details about pricing
i wish that we would but i think it's
gonna that's gonna be its own thing a
little later on
um in terms of you know releasing
making sure that that is you know given
the breathing room it needs
it can't be in amongst all the game
reveals i feel like you
very quickly overshadow some of the
things that you're showing off if you
just drop it in there like that
and obviously we live in a world where
everyone wants to do one
billion of these events for the rest of
the year so it's an easy way to
kind of segregate the key um
promotional points um and and have it
give longevity to your marketing
campaign around your new console
so this will be the first party game
hype um
uh stream and then we'll have the price
stream
and then the release date stream and
then the new color stream or something
like that they'll milk it for a bit so
for now i think it's going to be fairly
focused on the games
michael do you think that might hurt
them in the long run you know
i mean it's we're getting
closer and closer to the rumored release
date which is november
based on you know when things like
cyberpunk and
assassin's creed coming out but also
various comments from xbox themselves
they want to hit that release date in uh
just before christmas
the longer they hold out on not
discussing the
rumored other model and price do you
think that's going to hurt them in the
long run
because surely they would want to get
the pre-orders in
yeah i when you mention pre-orders i
think that's probably the big
factor in why you would want to probably
put this out there sooner rather than
later
but i don't i feel like i feel like the
series x is a is pretty much a known
quantity at this point
i think that a lot of people may have
already made up their minds
in terms of whether or not they're going
to go with the series x
and uh because they were uh xbox is out
of the gate first when they were talking
about
you know what it's going to offer specs
how these things are going to work
i think uh the the xbox hardware team
has been very
transparent about the things that
they're building out for series x
so there's been a consistent i would say
a consistent level of hype
in terms of hardware so i don't think
i don't think it would hurt them to
ignore that for now
uh because you know when whenever we
talk about
series x hardware there's a lot of
people who are like oh what about games
what about games what about games
and kind of talking about tam what tam
mentioned with the previous showcase
being
a little lackluster uh i think the
honestly i think the hardware stuff
has been more or less taken care of of
course price and release date are the
big questions
those can drop at any point and i think
microsoft will be safe
uh holding off on that for just a little
longer um
show us games first and i think that's
that's definitely what we're gonna get
and i don't
i don't think it's gonna hurt them to
just uh put hardware to the side for now
all right well let's get on to talking
about the games couple years ago to e3
phil spencer aka big phil as i call him
came to the stage
and he you know showed how much
microsoft were committing to first
parties and they bought a bunch of
studios they bought ninja theory
uh obsidian double fine all came into
the xbox family
they i think xbox game studios is
running in about 15 or so
studios now um i've made a list
let's go through them and see talk about
you know
what those last games were if we expect
to see anything from them today it's
been a good couple years
so hopefully a lot of them will have
something to show and obviously we're
going to be talking about the big boy
we're going to be talking about
the chief he's back we're very excited
to see him uh but let's talk about some
of these other studios first so i
mentioned ninja theory
damn i know you're a big fan of ninja
theory their acquisition by microsoft a
couple years ago
it's been a bit of a strange time for
them because they
released bleeding edge and
that was basically sent out to die in an
unfortunate way
um i hate to see it do you think they
were bought
for hellblade and you know
sadly bleeding edge was like let's just
get it out the door and focus all our
reese's resources on hellblade and how
do you think the studio
who has famously been you know this
incredible like double a studio how do
you think they're gonna cope
and fair under microsoft wing i think
i think they were they were bought for
more than just you know
hellblade and they're an incredible
studio that i
have a lot of affinity for mainly
because of what you said there they're a
double a studio
that where they used to be a double a
studio they're definitely not a double a
studio anymore now that they've been
purchased by microsoft
but they had that double a studio but
would love to roll up into the
aaa party and just start throwing its
way around with amazing ideas and
really interesting kind of mechanical
stuff and
beautiful games so i think i feel like
um
they also have project mario which they
showed off a little while back
um i doubt we'll get to see much more of
that
and honestly i don't expect i'm hoping
we
will get another look at um uh
hellblade too but at the same time i've
been keeping an eye on uh tamim
antoniades's uh
instagram he was like the one of the
founders of the studio
my man is off just having a good time
around the world right now so
who knows whoever they're actually like
if they've actually made any progress on
on kind of like
uh getting the game to the point where
they want to show off gameplay and stuff
but obviously it's not just one and one
man operation there's loads of people
working on the game and stuff and he's
probably
taking a well-earned vacation but i hope
we get to see more of this stuff
i would i think i'm more interested in
seeing what project mara is
and and the other kind of like
experimental stuff that they're working
on
then than a hellblade 2 for now i feel
like that initial trailer was enough for
me
but they're a studio that is just full
of amazing ideas they've achieved so
much
with comparatively a relatively lot less
resources available to them i feel like
they're one of those studios who's
really gonna
you know start to really hit its stride
under under microsoft's kind of uh
leadership and under the umbrella
because they have that kind of
safety net almost yeah
um michael anything else to add
uh hellblade 2 looks pretty dope but
i would like to see how they're going to
evolve the gameplay mechanics because i
think that was the one thing from
hellblade one which
like the the combat was fine uh it
worked well for what the game was going
for but i think that
you know it once you're under
microsoft's wing i guess the
expectations are
a lot different so and last thing i'll
say is like ninja theory has it in them
i think
when i think back to the previous games
uh like
dmc devil may cry like combat was
incredible there so i think
hubble a2 is a really good opportunity
for them to uh to
flex when it comes to that kind of thing
definitely all right let's move on to
obsidian so they actually have a game
coming out in
like four days uh grounded which is
basically like a honey i shrunk the kids
i personally don't think we'll see much
of grounded maybe like a little
trailer to build hype just before
release but phil spencer did tease that
they have another project in the works
time you're shaking your head i was
gonna say yeah we're not seeing grounded
but yeah
they did it that tease was one of those
like
pure like let's try and make this a fake
kind of like
a natural sounding thing but it's
obviously very pointedly saying that
they're gonna
they have something they wouldn't say
this unless it was like fairly likely it
was gonna show up soon
so i would expect we're gonna see
obsidian's
other game which is supposed to be a
more traditional rpg
in in the style of like um you know
star wars or fallout or something like
that
um i hope we can see that anyway
sorry oh sorry saying michael what do
you hope for it
i i just hope that the obsidian comes
out with
like sam saying like a really dope rpg
because obsidian is
has been one of my favorite studios
because they're willing to take risks
with the types of games that they make i
mean obviously star wars nigel republic
2
and follow new vegas are our established
franchises but their ability
to play off of those franchises and make
it their own
make it really stand out there's a
reason why we talk about those games in
particular is because
obsidian they they really go ham on
their style of game
of course they also have a reputation of
putting out games that are kind of buggy
at launch that are kind of
broken in some small ways because of
their ambition and how
how much they really go for it uh but
under microsoft i think
again like ninja theory the expectations
have changed to where
i at least conceptually i think that
they could put out a much more polished
product while still going ham on the
things that they're very good at
and whatever it may be whatever it may
be uh i'm here for it because
uh obsidian has a really good track
record with that stuff
and under under microsoft like the sky's
the limit i guess
another studio they purchased was undead
labs a developer of
a state of decay 2 which is kind of
being supported by dlc right now i
don't think we'll get anything
from them do you think
i mean like i who knows what what they
might have stored but like
they are a key developer for people
forget that they are like a pretty big
deal for microsoft in terms of what they
provide and also the kind of games that
they provide
say of the k2 didn't hit in the same way
that perhaps the first one did
um but there is a lot of love for it and
it improved
over time i think the important thing
about undead labs is they make those
kind of persistent games that are
one great for hooking people in and
keeping them around to
just absolutely perfect game pass fodder
like you put those kind of their kind of
games on game pass and it's like sea of
thieves
you know you're you're quite you're
getting a good um long-term
value out of that so it's one of those
um they they make games that are
interesting hooks for people or like uh
inviting hooks for people who might be
considering game pass
so who knows i feel like maybe they'll
use the opportunity to talk about undead
labs whether it's a new game or whether
it's like hey this is what we've done to
state of decay to make it um
interesting or like here's all the new
stuff that um
is coming to state of decay it would
make sense to use them in some
fashion but then again like maybe
they're not ready for
the next generation as as much as others
might be right now
yeah unless they're focusing still on
state of decay support
michael i'm gonna move on because we've
got like 15 minutes until
the um until the actual xbox first party
reveal
so in exile entertainment uh wasteland 3
bard's tale they also got purchased by
microsoft but let's move on
to double fine are you excited to see
some psychonauts
yeah i saw psychonauts 2 at e3 last year
wow ages ago man
uh and i you know i think uh
man e3 last year was like three years
ago but psychonauts too i i chopped it
up with uh with our boy
tim schaefer uh and greg rice when he
was there but
uh psychonauts twos is it's dope they're
i mean it's
it's that uh concept but pushed to
another level with like level design
and different types of trippy mechanics
that kind of play into the the themes of
psychonauts so uh it i think
it's been a little while since we've
heard from from them and like
psychonauts who's been one of those
things that
you kind of just know it's out there but
it kind of like
it'll come when it come whenever that
may be uh it'll be really cool to see
sucker knots too today because i think
that's something that's uh obviously the
first game is
very special i think the second one is
definitely hitting on those notes and
it's about time tim let's go
and actually like recently they were
saying that at the point just before
they became acquired by microsoft they
were having to cut things like boss
fights and
maybe not fully realize their vision so
it's actually a very story to see them
you know they were this champion of
indies for so long but then for them to
find their home with microsoft is
actually very sweet
i mean i i think double phone's a
fantastic studio it reminds me kind of a
lot like
you know how ninja theory operates in
almost like the double a space i hate to
create like
lines and boundaries between who makes
what and how it's you know
categorized but i feel like that um
double fine has been doing the same kind
of stuff in more the indie playground
like
creating smaller or you know kind of
more intricate games that are really
smart idea-wise i'd love to
obviously we're likely to see something
more of psychonauts so i hope anyway
but i would love for for microsoft to
kind of almost bring back the games that
um
now that it's a quiet double find that
they've done before like you know
costume quest is perhaps a little
overexposed
given how quickly they pumped out like a
themed dlc and follow-ups to it
but games like stacking for example are
like fantastic and really hold up still
i'd love it if they were like oh we're
gonna put all of double fines games
on you know make them available on game
pass and
and on um xbox series x or whatever it
may be
i hope that hasn't already happened and
i just missed it if so i'm gonna have a
great time later because i'm gonna check
but like i'd love to i love to play
stacking again
um and like even costume quests i love
to take another cracker and there's
there's a few other games that
that's in there kind of like a lineage
that uh that i think is worth bringing
back
and i think psychonauts is probably
going to be the big deal for them
but i'd love it if microsoft were like
hey we know why we know why
um double fine's so cool and we're gonna
let you figure that stuff out as well
here's all their games
all right moving on to a brand new
xbox first party studio called the
initiative so
i feel like this is they're trying to
build their version like they're trying
to get a prestige studio in
like naughty dog is to sony um
well i mean they're headquartered down
in the same place they're down in santa
monica
um according to jeff grubb from
venturebeat they're not
at this event allegedly that's you know
what jeff grubb says but
i'm holding that hope because it's very
interesting that kind of getting
together sort of some of the best of the
best talent you know you've got daryl
gallagher formerly crystal dynamics who
worked on tomb raider
ex naughty dog treyarch i'm very excited
to see
what a new studio and if they're gonna
really
funnel a ton of money into what they
could create
michael are you agreeing with jeff jeff
grubb
or do you think that grub snacks
yeah that's my guy man you know what
i'll just say this real quick i tweeted
at jeff grubb i said i grew up snacks he
was like damn that's ty and then he
changed his twitter name to grub snacks
and i was like all right i'll take that
w right there but
he's usually on the money so i'll uh
i'll
i'll go with that uh and i think that uh
i mean we haven't really heard much from
what the initiative
is necessarily doing so i mean
that could be the big surprise that
would be really cool uh but i really
have no compass in terms of that
i know we have here on the notes of
rumor perfect dark project
don't tease me don't tease me bro don't
tease me
bro yeah don't don't say perfect dark
man like uh perfect dark zero was kind
of
it was i it was that that 360 launch
game
360 launch game
[Laughter]
360 launch game we had to take what you
could could have got a time so
well i mean i put perfect dark project
in the notes because
uh and we'll talk a little bit about
fable as well
both of those have had uh very recently
registered twitter accounts which
microsoft immediately
you know people people saw that they
tweeted uh
they'd registered at perfect dark and
fable and microsoft were like
oh no you know we're just we're just
jumping on our brand stuff but it's like
really you didn't already have that one
um you don't really you don't really re
i think that their messaging is like
it's securing
the for it like so you know people will
just make sure that
you know i think that the actual point
was like people were squatting on these
earlier
and they just became available which is
why they now have like
secured it and their point is like we're
just doing it for the future but
we all know that's not the case like
they did it for fable
rumors of fable are happening they did
it for perfect dark and there's rumors
that the initiative is working on
perfect dark
i don't think we'll see anything from
that studio it's far too new i think
unless they've been like working as a
team or like working on the project
under another banner or something like
that it might be a bit too too early to
see what they've got cooking
um or it will and and to kind of
definitively say whether that's a
perfect dark or something else
there is this slight off chance that
they like do the just like a title
screen and show like
drawing a dark just like her face or
something like
something like that but um i don't
expect so but yeah
those those those kind of securing the
social uh
handles aren't a coincidence
uh all right let's talk about fable then
so
lionhead r.i.p um but the rumors have
been circulating for years
that playground games who frequently
work on the forza horizon series
um uh have been staffing up for an open
world rpg project
uh that rumor's been going around for
years recently as well microsoft opened
up a second playground
studio so it seems like that you know
half of that team is going to be on
forza horizon and half of that team will
be on this new fable project
hopefully we've got the the twitter
account
definitely michael do you think now's
the time we're ready to go back to
albion
uh i think i think we've been saying
this for for decades
not decades but many years you know i'm
ready for a fable
fable motorsport that's what i want you
know what i'm saying uh
no i actually i played i played the
replay the first fable
not too long ago actually uh and it held
up in in many
in many ways and i definitely saw like a
lot of the ambitions that they were
going for
way back uh when that game was first
hyped up
uh i wanna i want that same level of
hype again i wanna talk about
how you're gonna age through the game
and how you're gonna get old
uh through the story i wanna see that
stuff i wanna see how
you know i think that in talking to some
of the developers leading into series x
a lot of them are talking about
different technologies and how the the
series x
tech is going to fuel their games in
different ways in
unexpected ways i think about what fable
was talking about all the way back in
the day so i don't want to see i want to
see something
wild if they are going to talk about a
fable fable game of course like if that
were to happen we'll probably get like
you said a title screen or something or
just maybe like a few concept art or
like a like a
10 second trailer but fable would be
wild because
i think that uh xbox could use a
flagship rpg i mean
we talked about obsidian earlier but if
you have another huge rpg
and like i don't know man there's a lot
of people asking for fable man
you can you can really win some hearts
if you if
they come out with with something in
that regard what it might be
who knows but hey put up a title screen
and i'm hyped
let's go michael in the middle of that
something happened to your mic and you
sounded like kylo ren
why the droid
he's [ __ ]
there's something to be said about new
console generations really
bringing the excitement for kind of
these older titles we've seen it
let's talk about hate i mean time unless
you've got any pressing
fable comments now's your time
to chase some chickens ready to fart in
some faces and
be called hello hero that's about it
all right let's move on to chief then uh
because
we know that at least a bulk of this uh
show today is gonna be showing off the
first look in halo infinite gameplay now
since that game got released i got
revealed sorry
a couple of cgi trailers we don't really
have any clue or indication
from those as to how different this is
gonna be
for the halo formula you know halo three
arguably the last great halo game four
and five tried some new things
didn't really hit the mark in terms of
story especially um
what does halo infinite have to do to
kind of build
get halo back to its uh its position as
kind of
the daddy of first first person console
shoes
daddy
um i think it's halo's in a really
tricky position because what it needs to
do is be
innovative and new but also exactly what
it
used to be because i think that's a
situation
it put itself in by kind of virtue of
having
a few tepids to not great
last few releases which kind of got away
from what halo is and what fans love of
halo
so they moved away from master chief
which we've already seen they're kind of
remedying
and they tried to mix up the formula in
ways that
felt quite awkward try to like half step
into
modern fps trends so they find
themselves in a position now where they
need to be true to their lineage and
that means
for me personally a narrative focused
um halo game with master chief as the
main character
and then they also need to think about
how they can
uh kind of establish and lay the
foundations for the future of the
franchise
and be that in terms of the format of
the game the way it plays
or even like the narrative and
characterization so it's a tricky tricky
situation for them and what it seems
like they're doing is
is is kind of like they've shown off the
the box out of it feels like it's a good
indication that they know that's what
they need to do because they have the
the chief on the front which is the
homage to the first combat evolved
um boxer where he's just front on but
then you have the
the grappling hook what looks to be a
grappling hook on chief's
wrist which is kind of uh alluding to an
interesting new mechanical thing
my personal hope is that we get a kind
of
half kind of the game that i want that
i've allowed myself to create and think
that it is is metroid prime halo
where you have this kind of like world
that you're exploring
as master chief and you're kind of like
going to different biomes
and figuring out new new kind of puzzles
and
and battling enemies like the covenant
the flood unlocking new abilities
getting
further into this country because the
halo planets are always
a massive part of each experience and
each story but we so really get to dig
into really and experience them in their
kind of like
um totality and this would that kind of
idea would be an amazing way to approach
it like an almost
semi-open world halo game um but yeah
that's just my idea
for it at 343 industries if you're
listening
yes please michael what are you hoping
to see from halo
i just want to see some gameplay that's
what i want to see i mean we've we've
been talking about the nature of halo
infinite just by the name alone and what
from
from what the the cgi trailers are
implying to us
so i think it's about time that we had
those questions answered not that they
need any more pressure than they already
have coming out with with a major halo
game
alongside a new console launch so
i mean that's that's a tremendous
pressure and like uh this can be
one a perfect cap off for the xbox one
generation and a perfect start
for xbox series x uh so there's there's
a lot going on and we
want to see what the nature of this game
is already uh
because there's there's enough discourse
uh
and leaks and rumors and all that stuff
so i'm well i just want to put that to
rest
whatever it may be you know that
grappling hook stuff is uh i think
i think that's hype man like i think
folks were talking about on the slack
earlier yesterday where like
um you know master chief is the super
soldier but he
sometimes he moves like a brick i mean
he's got like a little bit of a floaty
jump which is which works
uh well and you can you can glitch jump
in halo 2 i remember doing that i was
like oh okay yeah master chief's got
some super powers but
uh man there's there's the it's
i think the halo infinite name means
that the the possibilities are endless
and you know what if tam's right on the
metroid prime style of gameplay
let's go even if it's like partially
that i think that putting
the strong halo gameplay foundation
that everybody knows and loves on top of
a brand new structure for the series is
wildly exciting uh and if it's semi-open
world i want to see
like you know well let's see what that
what that is first before we
jump on either side of hype or not hype
but yeah
i just want to see what this is at this
point if it's like a survival type of
game if it's
if it's a live service style of game and
how they're going to approach
multiplayer is that going to be a
separate
like so many questions that can be
answered today
that's actually what i'm looking forward
to more is just uh
finding out what this actually is did
you see that guy that world cup master
chief there
that dude looked like me three four
three four three put me in the game and
didn't give me any
credit royalty
i just loved millions i was like that
dude looks like me
he needs a headband yeah
we've got about a minute or so until the
actual showcase itself
so wild card predictions
i know it's a first party thing but
i'm sure tam will agree with me god
imagine if we saw the melbourne ring
god imagine it's not going to show up
though i can feel it i have
i have become synced with from software
so i can tell
i woke up today and my my spider my from
software sensors weren't tingling at all
um so i don't think so if it does happen
i would love it but i don't think so
no i mean i would i would love that and
also there have been the rumors that you
know
warner brothers interactive
entertainment are selling up shop
selling all their game studios if
xbox bought them that would be such a
cool for them
but i can't really see it happening
michael got about 30 seconds very very
quickly from you
wild card prediction final fantasy 14's
come to xbox baby the
best mmo rpg the one of the top three
games of all time
come to xbox bet
well for you i hope that happens don't
forget to join us
after the xbox showcase we're going to
be breaking down every single brand new
announcement i'm probably geeking out
over halo
so don't go anywhere here it is xbox
first party
uh showcase
i'm already
six
on
[Music]
[Music]
the mjolnir exosuit is now complete
even though this technology will save
humanity in the war to come
i must remind myself
liquid crystal cannot rise on its own
titanium alloy cannot prevail in the
face of extinction
it all means nothing
until you step inside
[Music]
ah
am i dead already i must be i mean
this is a punishment right
yep this is death
this isn't happening i'm going to have
to make an emergency landing
no yes no you
i can't stand it no you are
breathe no you don't get to tell me what
to do
you don't get to tell me anything we're
are you even listening i count three
anti-aircraft cannons
three what you'll be safe here
i'll be safe safe
i haven't been safe since i found you i
found you remember
you're out there on your own and you'd
still be out there if it wasn't for me
i thought i was going home there won't
be a home if we don't stop the banished
you keep saying that we're outgoing
outnumbered
i know i saw clone wars over there i'm
going to dig through them and find one
with the working sleep space drive
and when you're done with this war we'll
get away from here
far away wait here
oh please
let me see what i can find cannons first
when i get back we can look
[Music]
together
okay be god
uh
[Music]
so
hmm uh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
all foreign
oh
uh
the uranus lost this
war months ago your people
are broken scattered
hunted defeated
by me i wish i could tell you it was
difficult
but it wasn't
we are one step ahead always
the ring is already under our control
soon the auditorium is well
the harbinger and the banished share
the same goal we fight together
to honor the will of atriox
[Music]
without challenge i grew
weary lost
alone
but here
you now stand
this is my last
fight true test
of legends our story
will outlive us both
a fire in your heart spartan
bear your fangs
fight hard i
will
we hope you enjoyed your first look at
halo infinite's campaign
i'm incredibly proud of the team at 343
and we're thrilled to share a hint
of the epic battles that await you on
the next chapter of master chief's
journey
this is the most ambitious campaign
we've ever created at 343.
for the first time players will have the
freedom to explore a mysterious new halo
ring
that's several times larger than our
last two halo games combined
halo infinite has been built from the
ground up to take full advantage of xbox
series x
bigger battles epic vistas more complex
visual effects
displayed with 10 times the processing
power per pixel
of halo 5. this will be running at a
flawless 60 frames per second and will
allow us to bring the halo ring to life
in ways that have never been possible
before
we look forward to sharing even more
about halo infinite in the coming months
including the first look
at multiplayer and now please enjoy a
glimpse
of what others in the xbox game studios
family have been working on
world premiere
ah
[Music]
welcome everyone to the xbox game
showcase
today we're showing games from nine of
our 15
xbox game studios including unveils of
five new first party games what you will
see today
is how xbox game studios are harnessing
their passions
to bring their dreams to life we believe
that how you find and play your games
is as important as the device you play
them on
xbox game pass is the best way to
discover and play
and we want you to be able to experience
as many great games as possible
so game pass members you can play
every game you see today from your
subscription or free to play
these games will look and play best
on xbox series x delivering unmatched
fidelity
performance precision and immersion and
we've designed
the most consistently powerful next
generation console
and we've built state-of-the-art
platform technology
to allow every developer to realize
their full vision
one studio that has always pushed the
limits of our hardware
is turn 10 and they're early in
development
on the next forza motorsport and xbox
series x
is bringing them closer to their dream
of unprecedented realism
with ray tracing and native 4k
resolution
all at 60 frames per second
the trailer you're about to see was
captured
completely in engine
world premiere
[Music]
oh
[Music]
do
[Music]
our world has a rhythm
we all sense it
[Music]
but only a few truly feel it
it is found in the smallest moments
in every step of a perilous journey
in the symmetry of ritual
[Music]
in the bonds we share
[Music]
and in moments of stillness
[Music]
it teaches us to look beyond the
expected
to be a light in dark places
to seek answers
and to stand watch over our world
[Music]
our world has a rhythm
we all sense it
but only a few truly feel it
[Music]
everwild will give to you a magical
and untamed natural world for you to
explore
and to just truly lose yourself in it's
a place to be
eternal and eternal has the gift
to sense and feel how magic flows
through nature
and connects every living thing
the team here at rare are so excited to
be working
on something like everwild and i hope
you're excited too
but i just want to take this opportunity
to say a massive
massive thank you to everyone who's
shown their support
and love and for the incredible awesome
positive community that's already
growing around this game
thank you thank you thank you
whoa i just got hit with a flood of
memories
love you mom you seeing what i'm seeing
mom allison
it doesn't matter that they don't
believe us
we all believed that what happened that
night was self-defense
but we couldn't be sure
it doesn't matter that they kept us
apart brother
sister we look out for each other it
doesn't matter that finding the truth
feels impossible
we're all done with fairy tales the only
thing that matters
is you're my brother
and the only way to move forward
is to keep looking back
we've been getting these visions
whenever we see or hear something really
emotional
[Music]
everything we thought we knew about
marianne just got thrown out the window
she loved you she attacked you we both
saw it
[Music]
i thought coming here would be closing a
chapter of our lives
[Music]
nothing good comes from stirring up old
memories
we don't really have a choice about that
there's always a choice son
[Music]
i can't do this
hey everyone my name is gennady i'm the
co-founder and director of technology at
moon studios
today we are very excited to tell you
that we're working on a
very very special version of ori and the
will of the wisps
specifically for xbox series x we are
now at a time
where we can reach levels of fidelity
and frame rates previously absolutely
impossible on any console
an already gorgeous game like ori can
now run at 120 hertz refresh rate
in full 4k hdr in its highest quality
delivering unprecedented game feel with
silky smooth animation
super crisp sharp image and low input
latency which is just so important
for the tight and precise platforming
feel of this game
we can also boost the immersion in
different spaces
in our world by using premium audio tech
that we previously just could not
simulate in real time
and with all of this crazy hardware
power we can give
our players more options with how they
want to play our game
we can't wait for all of you to
experience this very special version of
ori
coming to xbox series x with smart
delivery later this year
from the furthest reaches of the
universe comes the biggest mystery
in the galaxy an abandoned research
facility and now
shady corporate intrigue marvel by the
gorgon asteroid
assorted stopover full of salacious
secrets
and scandalous strangers greetings
attractive patreon you
are looking down right on a global today
with the right kind of case they wanted
us to develop a miracle drug
can put you on the wrong side of a gun
or sword or this
thing
[Music]
thrills danger
intrigue a word of advice before you go
captain
trust no one
what will you find on gorgon
this unit cannot bring you any drinks in
its current state
if you're waiting
for the biggest game of the year
then wait for cyberpunk
but if you're ready for the smallest
got you covered
from obsidian entertainment the makers
of games
that are nothing like this one
this summer strive together
to thrive together or just feed your
friend to the spiders
and go solo
[Music]
at obsidian we're dedicated to pushing
narrative and role-playing games
it's something we do every day when we
come to the office and we can't wait for
you to play our next great adventure
parallel on gorgon
it's the first of two planned story
expansion packs for the outer world that
we're putting together with our friends
from the private division now it's also
important that we continue to evolve how
we tell stories in games
and grounded is the perfect example of
that the team has been working for the
last two years
on how to tell an obsidian story within
a survival game
now what's great is that you're going to
be able to play the game on july 28th
on xbox game preview and on steam early
access we want to hear from you and we
want to continue to build grounded
together
oh yeah if you've been wondering we have
been working on that next big obsidian
rpg
check this out world premiere
[Music]
we have always known war
it forged our empire
turned heroes into queens and kings
and decimated our foes
now our oaths are lost
forsaken
and you must face the monsters
[Music]
our sins have borne
is an oath worth the weight of a crown
avowed is an expansive first-person rpg
set in the fantasy world of eora when
obsidian entertainment joined xbox game
studios
they told us that this epic game is the
one they want
to make as creators of critically
acclaimed rpgs
this is obsidian at their best and it is
being built from the ground up
to take full advantage of the power of
xbox series x
at xbox game studios we also work with
independent developers
always with the goal of empowering them
to bring
their ideas to life i'm excited to
announce our work with
interior night a new studio led by some
of the most talented storytellers in our
industry
let's meet caroline marshall studio head
of interior night
to debut their original game bonjour
i'm caroline from interior night our
team is really passionate
about interactive storytelling because
when you play your story
you step into the character's shoes you
get to experience their fears their
hopes
their conflicts firsthand and in the
process
you learn more about yourself and this
is quite powerful
our first game spans 30 years in the
american southwest it's a story about
family resilience and sacrifice but most
of all
it's about how you will shape the fate
of real
flawed people trying to find their way
in the world they don't fit in i hope
you enjoy the trailer
world premiere
fortune fashion smile and fade i haven't
seen
you much of late i need you now i cannot
wait
to look you're not around we were on our
way to start a new life that summer
for our family it was just a stopover
[Music]
mine it was the end of the road
on the ground now the sun went down
on all of us that day
was it fate coincidence
no that was a long forgotten secret
buried in the dark
all my life i've been scared of the
shadows
but now i'm finally ready to step into
the light
i got your letters
here at ninja theory we're hard at work
on all of our projects
including senua saga hellblade 2 which
we announced at the game awards
back in december
an incredible 3.5 million players have
now experienced
senua's story in hellblade senua's
sacrifice
we're excited to start giving you an
insight into what comes next for our
celtic warrior
an experience that we'll be building in
unreal engine 5
for xbox series x and pc
i'm happy to reveal today that senua
saga will be set in the beautiful
country
of iceland
and you can find out more about our
location scouting and how we've
discovered the history of our setting
in a brand new behind the scenes
development diary which you can view
straight after the show on the ninja
theory youtube channel
it's been so touching to see the impact
that hellblade central sacrifice has had
on
so many players and we're incredibly
thankful to all of the fans that have
been part of senua's story so far
and we're excited for you to be part of
our development journey
from here on out
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
do i say hi to peter he's on the line
what peter peter has been sitting there
the whole time
hey who wrote the song uh peter
oh peter fantastic work love the song
very much it's gonna be fun to sing it
now it's time to
to rock shall we start rocking
[Music]
probably been a long time since you've
had a visitor
i hope you don't mind poppins
where are we it's a quiet place
[Music]
lost alone
neither skin nor warm
just a thought is all i've got
now my cover's blown
at the bottom of a lake
a frozen feeling
when my friends pulled me back up
i started
but now i sense
[Music]
and i can't taste the sky
and i can't see each molecule
through my cosmic eye
[Music]
sensors are the magic keys
unlocking all my memory
[Applause]
which are never
[Music]
[Applause]
never
we can't wait for you to experience the
amazing games built by xbox game studios
and there is just so much more for you
to play
on xbox we are partnering with thousands
of creators
from the largest publishers to the
smallest independent developers
to bring you the broadest variety of
games ever
there is one developer in particular
that is close to us
not just geographically but in history
too
i'm thrilled to announce that this fall
our friends at bungie will bring destiny
2
to xbox series x and xbox
game pass if you are one of the more
than 10 million game pass subscribers
you also get access to
all current destiny 2 expansions
starting this september
for game pass ultimate members destiny 2
will also be playable
on mobile from the cloud
later this year bungie will also release
a new version of destiny 2
that is optimized for xbox series x 4k
resolution running at 60 frames per
second
here's an all-new look at bungie's
destiny 2 beyond light
i've seen terrible things born out in
the darkness
every moment brings them closer
it's time to step beyond the light
[Applause]
this is destiny 2 that you can play any
way you want
thanks to xbox game pass some of the
world's most inspired developers are
working on games for xbox series x and
we're just honored to be able to
collaborate with them
xbox series x will empower both new and
experienced creators
to bring the future of games to life
like never before
unique perspectives unexpected
innovations
and fresh voices that demand to be heard
and that we can't wait for you to
discover
all of the games you're about to see are
being built to launch
exclusively on xbox consoles
thanks and enjoy
world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
world premiere
[Music]
my lord inquisitor i've reached a term
of prime
and begun our investigations
our recon squad has been sent into
sub-level six of the hive
to determine the full extent of the
unrest
i'll know more when they make it back
if they make it back
world premiere
when you were born something
[Music]
of changed world and all that it
creates
[Music]
with every passing day the winds might
grow stronger and carry us away
[Music]
does not escape
[Music]
don't forget
[Music]
world premiere
[Music]
approaching orbit scans a no-go sure you
want to drop here
so yeah already lacing up my boots back
here
[Music]
hold on let me check
find anything good
you're not gonna believe this
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
it all starts with a dead girl
a forest the moon
scent of pines
and then
the gunshot
every story has two sides
a regular rational one
but also a darker and deeper truth
not unlike a nightmare
i can see both worse
i can lift them
hello anyone there
what is this place
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
machine
and everything
world premiere
[Music]
so
[Music]
i've seen your future
global risk is scared of the weapon
you will become
destiny chose me to save this world
and i will see it done
[Music]
blacklist we make our own path we
protect our own
can you protect me from fate
17 seconds
soon the entire world will burn
all because of
the ghost him here
[Applause]
today you saw 10 world premieres
and 22 console launch exclusives
game pass members can play every game
you have seen today
from xbox game studios and all of our
partners
in the subscription or free to play this
is just a peek
at some of the new titles coming to xbox
series x
and some of the games you already love
and some you have yet to play
will also be optimized for xbox series x
games like forza horizon 4 gears 5
and sea of thieves you'll get the next
gen
upgrades at no additional cost when they
launch
you can expect a lineup of over 100
titles
for xbox series x this holiday season
with series x and game pass
xbox is the place to play and you
are at the center of everything we do
now you may have noticed we didn't get
to visit all of our xbox game studios
today
that means we'll have more to share
later this year
but until then here's one more thing
world premiere
[Music]
the world is filled with stories
of legendary heroes
and treacherous villains
of fantastical creatures
and wondrous places
where nature and magic
live in perfect harmony
[Music]
not all stories have happy endings
but yours has yet to be written
[Music]
right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to gamespot's
xbox first party showcase post show
god that was a sentence and a half i'm
lucy joined by michael hym
what up we're back and hussein
hello and sushi
who's in the background of michael's
shots um
she's made she's made a cameo in like
most of the stuff we've done over the
summer
and i didn't want her to feel left out
that i didn't introduce her uh all right
so
microsoft showed off a ton of first
party games there and a couple of third
party we saw some stuff from don't knot
in there too
uh let's go through the showcase break
it down say what we thought about all of
the reveals
let's kick off with the show opener halo
infinite i honestly expected them to
close with it but i guess closing on
fable makes more sense because it's the
big
surprise thing halo tam you and i've
been playing halo again recently what
did you make of infinite
i'm excited um we've been playing master
chief collection which
despite various improvements it has come
a long way but it's still
not a great way to play that game over
co-op
over the um distance we have playing
with our friends in england but
um i'm excited for what i've seen of
infinite so far
we talked about it needing to be
something different while also needing
to be very familiar and it definitely
felt like that
and it opened the way of chief kind of
hopping out onto a new planet
and um very much evoked the first game
and had a lot of similar beats to it um
and then very quickly kind of pivoted
into showing off what was new
with the grappling hook the map you know
we talked about having a
uh kind of open world-ish metroid prime
ish type game and it does look like
that's what they're doing
to some degree um the grappling hook
seems like it's
just the start of something i don't i
feel like there's going to be more
interesting gameplay hooks for one of a
better term
um but this is a really good start it
looked familiar it sounded familiar it
it had just enough for the smart tweaks
that felt like this makes sense for halo
and not necessarily chasing trends
like the sprint is in there but it makes
sense um
the grappling hook is a new thing that
it showed like traversal and also combat
uses for it
which is really cool um we've got like a
interesting set up for a story with the
banished and so we'll see how that
develops
uh yeah i'm excited for it i like what
i've seen so far
michael you excited for halo yeah i want
to play some halo halo's a lot of fun
it's just uh it's very simple
straightforward uh type of fun but
there is there's a lot going on i think
just from the small
the short gameplay demo that we got um
this is gonna be an open world
and there's gonna be like upgrade pads
and things like that so i'm also
thinking that there's gonna be a lot of
emphasis on exploration
uh which is fairly new for halo you know
we were used to going through missions
and stuff like that of course
odst toyed with that concept a little
bit
um but man this is yeah it's it's it's
pretty hyped to see
halo try something different like tam
said and
both hit notes of the familiar and the
new
i wanna i would like to see multiplayer
stuff but of course you know that's
not what they were going for here in
this demonstration
there's so much more that they they
probably have uh
up their sleeves so i think this is
enough for me to
kind of uh not necessarily sell me on
halo infinite but
to show off like that they are they are
trying some new stuff
and uh yeah i mean i wanna i wanna get
hands on with this
uh we're gonna see more uh soon but
yeah i mean let's play let's play halo i
wanna i wanna know what the co-op is
gonna look like in the single-player
stuff too
or in this campaign with this open world
i think uh that's definitely a question
that i'm gonna have uh as we look more
into this game because open world co-op
could be
a ton of fun and i don't know how
they're going to pull that off and but
there's
some cool mechanics that i'm excited to
dive into that
that can change the halo formula that
we're kind of uh familiar with
after all these years i'm very
interested
in uh the flawless 60 frames per second
comment um i really hope that doesn't
come back to bite them on the ass and i
hope that it does run
as buttery smooth as it looks here um
that was very much the big theme
for xbox uh i feel like when they were
showing off all these new games they
were like
everything is either running in like
native 4k 60 frames
um and they're really trying to showcase
the power of
the series x and i think they did a good
job with halo i think it was a great
uh way to open because like i said
before the show um
[Music]
a new console launch you get the chance
to tap into those feelings of nostalgia
and what a way to do them with halo kind
of the biggest
most recognizable certainly xbox
franchise
um last time they launched a new console
launched with a halo game was way back
in 2001
so if you think about the people who
grew up with halo as a franchise they're
the people who are
being definitely targeted by xbox to
invest in a series x so i think that was
a very smart
way to start one thing i will say about
the halo presentation is that
definitely they needed to get the story
elements across but i felt the little
uh monologue from the guy at the end
who looked like an orc from lord of the
rings maybe went on a little bit more i
would have liked to have seen a bit more
gameplay um that guy's revenant in apex
legends i believe
um but you know i think it's good to get
the stakes there
uh and it's certainly enough people more
excited to see more gameplay
uh specifically co-op and multiplayer
and like they said there's gonna be more
xbox
uh they're gonna do more of these uh for
the rest of the year
as we lead up to the series x launch
so unless we've got anything else
pressing about halo
not really it looks pretty much what we
wanted
so saying yep let's move on then
to a game that we all said wasn't gonna
show anything we thought the focusing
still on supporting state of decay 2
and then now they came out of the gate
with a cool looking
cgi trailer for i don't know i honestly
i'm not sure what i thought this was
um i figured some kind of survival game
but
i mean i didn't expect state of decay 3
quite so quickly but i thought this was
a cool trailer um
[Music]
tam what do you make uh are you are you
going to delve into this one are you
going to give in to mike mccarty's peer
pressure
yeah as we yike my hearty loves us
loves the second game um so i i feel
obligated to
to kind of at least check that one out
um this one out sorry um yeah not a lot
of
um obviously with cgi trailers it's hard
to kind of get across the intricacies of
how you're gonna play it but
i think like i said earlier this is a a
kind of a franchise for xbox that has a
lot of popularity but perhaps doesn't
have the same like
attention and doesn't get the same kind
of like public facing
like uh showmanship of how how amazing
everyone
thinks it is and that kind of stuff so
it's it's it's one of those things where
i feel like as a game pass game which
many
remote almost all of these games i
believe are um
it's gonna be one to definitely kind of
have on your xbox and dip in and out of
so that's what i'm kind of looking
forward to it being for me
a kind of persistent uh game that i can
keep coming back to
because the first game and the second
game had some really interesting and
satisfying mechanics to it
it was just i thought the second game
was a bit more uneven
in in various parts so i feel like
they've got a good opportunity here to
really come in strong with a a kind of
uh
lifestyle game early with the xbox
series x and
have people commit to it and play it for
a long time
michael are you gonna dip in i don't
know if state of decay is necessarily my
thing but i respect
it uh i know that we we talked about how
uh mike mccarty was
putting in for 400 hours he says and i
don't doubt it
uh but uh that the game launched with i
think a lot of mixed reactions like some
people were really
into its systems but were kind of held
back by some of its jankiness
of course it came out with a bunch of
dlc and a lot of support afterwards and
i think uh aaron sampson did
a whole video on how that game had
evolved with its dlc and its updates
and it seemed like it got to a really
good place which is why state of decay 3
announcement is kind of surprising maybe
this is
a bit more of a ways out than we may
think
because of the state of state of decay 2
and
how recent it is but this is also going
to a
very different type of environment i
think that state of decay 2
was very much in kind of like
not necessarily on the force but it was
just like very
basic environments and stuff like that
but i think that
going to something that looks a lot
different might be a function of
gameplay as well so
i think if stated k3 were to
kind of i guess sell me on its concepts
or evolving its concepts
i think integration of its environment
might be fascinating
uh and uh yeah uh how it might leverage
series x power in that regard might also
be
be a thing so i don't know i think that
they i feel like undead labs may have
learned a lot from the launch of stated
k2
and how that game evolved so uh i'm
leaning more towards the hype of sage k3
so
well yeah that's my thoughts
all right and next up we also saw a game
that i think we all saw coming
uh ten ten are always kind of the
a standout when it comes to showing off
the graphical fidelity of any xbox
console machine
we got a look at a brand new forza
motorsport so this would have been forza
eight eight motorsport eight it would
have been
about eight it's i wonder if they're
dropping the numbered
iterations at this point because
eight is a lot will i understand the
story
like water one two seven what are they
what are the relationships between these
cars
like we need to catch up but i think i
think the
what this speaks to is like again one of
the big themes of this show was game
pass
and this i think this is a very obvious
attempt uh if they do indeed keep it as
forza motorsport attempt at establishing
forza as an ongoing platform on game
pass
so no more like isolated um game
releases
just have a forza that you get access to
when you sign up to game pass and it's
just the forza for this generation
and it is the game that they'll support
turn 10 will support
daily weekly monthly for for the
lifetime of xbox series x
i think that's what they're probably
going for with this
yeah i think so too it makes sense
michael what do you think
yeah i mean we've we live in a world
where it's all about live services and
subscriptions and i think as someone
who's played racing games since he was
five years old i guess uh i would
prefer racing games to go that way uh
because
at a certain point you're kind of like
okay why would i buy
the next one or the next one that's just
like two years apart because that's kind
of the cadence of of motorsport
uh the the sub-franchise for forza and
you know just continual updates would be
would best serve this so i guess again
that that's why you would drop the
number
it's tied to game pass of course and uh
yeah
i guess that would also it wouldn't make
sense if you're gonna push game pass so
hard too it wouldn't make sense to
have numbered releases two years at a
time
things like that but um i'm leaning more
towards the horizon series but i
i respect motorsport in that regard so
uh and of course
it's it's such a forza is such an easy
thing to show off xbox hardware
they did it with forza motorsport 7 when
the xbox one
x was about to launch three years ago so
then
having the new motorsport again to show
off the series x like okay i get it
uh but yeah it's uh games are looking
much better than real life at this point
i mean things aren't really that shiny
out here uh looking out my window things
looking real drab but hey if you give me
a foes of forza motorsport with
nicely polished cars i might be on board
y'all
and they said it's going to be
supporting ray tracing native 4k
60 frames i think if any any of the
series x games has to do it it has to be
a forza to really show off
the powerhouse that is the series x
console um
i'm particularly i'm like you i lean
towards the horizon i'm not really that
much
for racing games in general but when i
do i prefer the more arcady feel
but i do like you said have the greatest
of respect for forza because it just
looks
incredible i'm just aware that it's a
game that's not for me i can't even
drive in real life
so why yeah
i know it's it's my you know what my
list of things to do but funnily enough
in the middle of a pandemic i don't want
to get into a car with a stranger and
learn
but uh let's move on then to rare
so no mention of perfect dark from the
initiative from rare from anyone but
res game ever while it has already been
announced uh got a nice little kind of
gameplay trailer
uh it looks it looks really pretty i
like the art style a lot um
series x and pc only it said tam what'd
you make of this one
yeah i think it looks interesting it's
it looks
to be a little more like i'm excited to
see rare go back to making a game that
isn't like a live service game
um as far as i can tell this isn't this
is just like a straight-up adventure
where you're kind of exploring a world
and
and it might not look like the classic
rare stuff where it's you know
banjo-kazooie or whatever maybe donkey
kong these kind of
like quirky almost saturday morning
cartoony type experiences
but what they showed looks like it still
could have the fundamentals of what they
do really well which is
really fun memorable worlds and
creatures
that you get to explore and and kind of
like collect things in
and dig deeper into and kind of like
have fun with
um i really like that they like have
this it felt like a lot like avatar to
me as well
like yeah you have to get in tune with
the elements and and the net natural
world
there's like that weird massive monster
thing that looks kind of like upper
which i i'm big into this fish lad is
absolute legend just eating all the
fishes i feel i feel him
um but yeah it looks like it's it looks
really good i'm interested to see how
the gameplay kind of shakes out before i
kind of commit to whether i feel like
it's gonna be worth my time or not um
but for
four i've seen so far it's a little more
close to what i
love about rare and what i want from
rare which has me excited
i'm just very glad that they are letting
rare
make games again and not just connect
and not just uh pieces of software to
bell connect units
let's just put it that way um
michael what do you think of everworld
uh i think it's a nice juxtaposition to
going from forza motorsport as this big
huge
showcase for new hardware and look at
all these shiny cars and then you go to
something that is very much in tune with
a creative art style uh i think that you
know
it's kind of funny that rare would go
would also have cfps which kind of also
has like
that kind of quirky cartoonish art style
uh in a vast beautiful open world
as uh as i think sea of thieves as
so going into this like you know i i
would lean towards you know seeing their
creative imagination go to work for
something like this rather than
something like like super
high fidelity or whatever but uh in
terms of i don't know if
the information's out there in terms of
what the gameplay can be but if they can
if rare can kind of channel some of the
things that they learned from sea of
thieves over the years because that game
has become something
uh pretty notable at this point if they
can kind of channel some of that energy
into this and maybe do i don't know
like like tam said maybe some some
avatar style vibes but maybe in a
monster hunter style of game
that would be wild um of course i'm just
speculating but
uh yeah this is i'm gonna keep my eye on
this
uh big time so uh yeah ever wild rare
go get it let's go
all right we have so many more games to
kind of blast through so
uh let's move on to don't nod
entertainment so i thought this was all
gonna be first party stuff but then
don't not show it up
um with tell me why tam
tell me why oh my god
that was all he was doing while we were
watching the show but
so very obviously big life is strange
vibes
episodic first episode coming out august
27th uh
i will say like graphically and engine
wise it looks a lot better than life is
strange and i don't mean that in a life
of strange look bad life exchange was
very much
you know a last gen game um
but it had its criticisms especially
when it came to things like lip sync
um but this one looks a lot more natural
it looks it looks cute it looks
very melodramatic it looks very dope not
um
i'm intrigued to see and hear more about
it um
and like yeah i like that they have
their audience and i think don't nod
does
i think donut knows what it does best
and that's definitely what tell me why
it looks like they're recording too
uh so tell me why is
i'm gonna ke i'm keeping my eye on this
big time because i think that they can
hit something
really important with this uh because
the the main character is a trans man
and that's uh that's uh something that
they have to get right uh they also have
a uh a trans
uh man of voice voicing the this
character as well so
to me this comes off as them trying
their like they're actually going for it
to trying to tell and earn a story
and with dope nods history with life
life is strange too
in particular i think is they have a
good track record of telling these
impactful stories
in um in meaningful ways that aren't
that i think that they get right
especially with life estranged two
and uh you know portraying the latinx
experience
in that game and then here where they're
trying to
at least from this trailer it really
feels like they're leaning into
trying to communicate the a a sort of
a trans man narrative and i think that
they can
i would lean towards them getting it
right of course i want to see more how
that plays out but
you know putting this out as on an xbox
showcase on the front stage is very bold
and i think it's very important
so i hope that they can knock it out of
the park with this one
me too um i'm always rooting for donut i
think
they're a very talented bunch and i
think the first life is strange game in
particular
is something that's very special to me
so i really hope that tell me why
kind of is another is another good hit
for them uh all right let's move on
ori is uh willow the wisps is coming to
series x
uh they can run at 120 frames a second
uh and it's coming with smart delivery
so it looks nice i mean
yeah great uh i don't mean that
dismissively
i think ori is a beautiful game and i
honestly was very surprised by the first
game when it came out a few years ago i
haven't had a chance to get around to
the sequel just yet
but the fact that it's still being
supported and brought to a brand new
console
good uh and similarly we've got outer
worlds
not wilds out of worlds dlc from
obsidian peril on gorgon which is coming
uh quite soon i think september 9th uh
looks fun i didn't actually finish out
the worlds myself
you guys excited to go play some more
time i'll go to you first
yeah yeah um definitely want to check
out more of it um
it's that that experience was
it's kind of like understated but it's
probably one of the best fallout games
in
in a long time you know they kept it
short they kept it sharp
kept it tight it was really well written
and
mechanically was satisfying to play a
lot of memorable characters and
there's a lot of opportunity in that
world i'm glad to see that they're
sticking with it a bit and
kind of exploring a little more of it so
yeah i'm excited to jump back in
and get more time in that world
and also from obsidian uh grounded
uh which is basically honey i shrunk the
kids the game coming out in
something like four or five days time in
kind of early access uh xbox preview
which looks really cool
uh michael what do you think uh you know
it's it's cool it's not real i don't
think it's gonna be my style of game
uh but i know that there's a lot of
folks who get hooked on these these
styles of games it's like
rust but light-hearted and uh i think
that there's definitely space for
something like that
uh and if this could be like microsoft's
premiere game of that style
uh that would that would be dope i would
be happy for the people who are looking
for that sort of thing
uh and also obsidian this is this is
we've talked about this before
because grounded isn't necessarily this
isn't a new reveal
but we are seeing more of it but this is
new territory for obsidian
and uh that that's that's really they
even said it here they was like playing
off of that too they were
trying to be cheeky and all that uh
they're like wow this is from a studio
that never makes these kinds of games
and um yeah i think that this that's a
studio that
has a history of like we said in the
pre-show of
doing these bold concepts with things
that we kind of already know or think
are established uh so i i'm gonna keep
my eye on this one as well i'm not
sure if i'm gonna be uh playing it but
you know props to them for trying
something new
uh and uh yeah this is gonna be
like early access playable it's going to
evolve this is the type of game that
of course has like a live service
evolving structure so you know
props to them also an incredible dunk on
themselves with that cyberpunk joke
um well let's talk about a gay like
let's talk about
what obsidian are best known for what
they're great at
that's rpg uh and so their next one was
revealed today
avowed um which
actually takes place uh i was checking
in on slack takes place in the pillars
of eternity
uh world which kind of explains why
there was a big
pillars of eternity sign behind um
uh the spokesperson while he was
introducing the game but
it looks i mean i don't know how much
you can really take from a cgi trailer
but honestly i
love that fantasy [ __ ] so i'm
really into this one you know me
there's a point where we were like what
are the rings in it
um i see more of it
time yeah yeah i think um
obsidian as a studio they always like
put an interesting spin
on familiar formats or familiar ideas
you know they're known for working in
star wars working in fallout and
at the risk of being reductive it feels
a little like
they're feeling the elder scrolls-shaped
hole um
that is currently in existence uh you
know we've got a
we need a new skyrim um i'm sure
possessed there will release skyrim for
next year anyway but um
in in the kind of like in place of that
they've they've kind of taken
some of the what they people probably
loved about skyrim and mixed it with
what they almost certainly love about
political attorney which is
a lot of fun and critically acclaimed um
uh
franchise in itself and i feel like it's
a good way to put a
new breathe new life into the skyrim you
know elder scrolls style format
and while playing to your own strengths
and working with your own ips
so i'm excited to see more of that stuff
if they can
you know do what they did for uh do what
they did with fallout with new vegas for
skyrim and well up for that
i was gonna say because i think we're
getting uh we're getting starfield
before we're even getting
elder scrolls six right so this is
something that's definitely going to
bridge the gap and
i am very into that it looks really cool
um i just want to see more of it
uh moving on then as the dusk falls kind
of
uh more of a visual novel style game um
honestly unexpected in a series x
showcase but um i don't know it's i
don't think it's for me i'm not really
that
into visual novels um michael
are you gonna play i am i love visual
novels but i'm more into the weeb [ __ ]
if you know what i'm saying uh so
but i mean like it's it's kind of hard
to make out what this game is
uh because the the reveal was i don't
know it wasn't really
detailed or whatever but it has like a
colorful art art style you know the
people's putting
shoving guns in each other's faces i'm
like oh whoa relax
uh so this is my this might be something
that's gonna that's gonna be heavy
uh and uh you know i i like that
microsoft has a well-rounded kind of
roster of games because you have things
like tell me why
uh with its narrative focus that's
trying to go in deep on something that
uh that looks to be impactful so and
then having something like
this here show it off alongside all of
its big
aaa stuff you know uh i respect that as
well but
of course i want to see more see what
the nature of this is what they're what
they're trying to say
uh with this game so uh yeah but uh
definitely keep keeping my eye on this
as well
yeah it's really it makes a lot of sense
for them to have this kind of game
um in in the showcase if only you know
to make sure that it's well-rounded and
they're representing more than just
shooters you know
tell me why ain't nothing but a
heartbreak but this is still interesting
to have
in in there um to kind of round that off
all right let's move on to uh ninja
theory and hellblade tam you
accidentally
unintentionally called this when you're
talking about to meme traveling all over
the world
uh with the uh
revelation that the game is actually
gonna be set in iceland how do you feel
that's twice i did the metroid prime
open world halo as well and then i was
like maybe it's you know
you know a globetrotting different
location for for the for the whole uh
heavenly heavenly sword oh my god
hellblade
wow mate old games
uh but yeah uh they showed off the cgi
stuff again
um which looks really really cool um i
wanted to kind of
hope that we'd get some gameplay out of
it but sadly not
instead they kind of just showed up and
we're like hey we're in iceland if you
want to see what we're up to check this
out
uh wildflex and there's like yeah
wildflex
um but yeah they're going to be
releasing like a behind-the-scenes
location scout documentary on their um
channel which
uh if you watch the stuff that they did
for hellblade the first game was really
interesting because they
kind of dug into the process of making
games and it was one of the most
like behind one of the most valuable
behind the scenes experiences that a
game developer has released because they
really
showed off like the difficulties of of
what it was like to make a
double a game at a aaa kind of level so
it's interesting it's going to be
interesting to see what
how that contrasts with what they're
doing now when they
they've got the microsoft money is it
going to be the same kind of like
we're taping stuff together to make it
work or it's going to be like we're in
iceland we just come out this five-star
restaurant we're gonna go look at some
icebergs now
because we need to do that
um all right let's move on to
psychonauts then
god for a second there i saw jack black
he and tim schaefer are both wearing
brutal legend shirt i thought it was
gonna be
brutal legend 2 but
actually honestly jack black on the
soundtrack for psychonauts 2. i'm well
into that
um i love the relationship that he has
with double fine
also djiblinski games is fantastic so
but always excited to see more jack
black
in video games michael what did you
think of the presentation because have
you
did you get to go hands-on with
psychonauts no we
at e3 when i mentioned it earlier in the
pre-show it was a
it was a live demo of someone else
playing it so i
i do know how this game is going to play
uh so
i think oh i mean for me it's sort of a
known quantity
at this point you know uh that's that's
not disparaging in any way
uh but it's kind of like i've seen this
game in action already so
come on i want to get my hands on it but
i think also psychonauts
is also a very visual experience so
you know giving us more looking into uh
how it's going
to be playing on its concepts uh it's so
it's such a creative thing man like
it's such a such a mind like um i was
gonna
man i don't want to say that it's like
yeah it's very uh
it's trippy man and you know having jack
black on the soundtrack it's
cool the tim schaefer and jack black got
a got a cool thing going on so uh yeah
i just uh man i i was almost expecting a
little bit more gameplay because i don't
think
i can't recall if that gameplay that we
saw was public
i think it is but um yeah yeah
yeah so i don't know i keep the hype
going come on
um i'm ready for psychonauts too give it
to me
uh and just like so the ps5 uh
showcase from a few weeks ago launched
with gta 5
um we have an equivalent yeah destiny 2
coming uh to game pass uh destiny 2 all
this expansions
but also there's going to be a version
that bungie are working on to optimize
it for series x coming out later this
year
um i have dipped my toe into destiny
more so with destiny 2 uh a number of
times
i don't know you okay
i don't know if i can do it again uh is
all i'm saying i know i've
tried i know i tried to convince you
into it
it's just one of those games where i
feel like because i didn't keep up with
it from the beginning i
don't know if i can jump in now you know
like two
three years after release uh there's so
much to destiny that i'm
like i know destiny but i don't know
destiny like people you can talk about
the lore
different weapons and different
abilities and light levels and i'm just
completely lost
um but you know it's kind of nice to see
bungie
having that relationship with xbox again
because obviously they were at the
uh ps4 uh reveal event back in 2013
and now you know back on xbox's stage
they're flirting with all the
the big boys time you're gonna play
destiny
probably i got i keep dipping in and out
of it um
if it's on game pass i really have no
reason not to to try it out i know a
bunch of people
on xbox that play it um i have i have
gone back to destiny a bunch of times
and
seen kind of like the improvements that
they've made and checked in anytime
something big happens and
there's a lot to like about that game
even if you're not super into the
um kind of law part of it is there's
ways
i think the key of key thing is you need
someone who knows what they're doing to
kind of guide you through it
um and that's my plan for the xbox
series x version i'm gonna grab
probably chris pereira and and get him
to like walk us
walk me through some of the cool stuff
because i started doing that but
he plays david ahmadi plays constantly
phil hornshaw plays it
we've got michael joe who plays it so
there's a good game spot squad
of people who are on there so i think
once it comes around i might i might be
like
tag me in cultures uh to train me up and
and we'll go from there
i was gonna say because i do think
destiny 2 is some of the best
uh feeling shooting of any game
i really like the way that it feels to
play um i just don't
i think i just only really have time for
one
online investment so to speak and that
for me is overwatch
apex it's overwatch we just delve into
apex a little bit but it kind of depends
on your time
but let's move on to a game that i know
michael was very very excited about
and honestly the one that i don't think
anyone really saw coming uh
stalker 2 michael tell us why you're so
excited about this one
i'm so excited about stalker 2 because i
just know that it's real
uh like leading up to this point all we
knew about stalker 2 was that it had a
website
and had some uh had like
20 21 on the website and then it had
like some music tracks some ambient
music tracks i'm like
okay cool the the actual name stalker 2
has gone through
so many different wild
uh things like it was initially going to
be like a sequel
like 10 years ago then that completely
got scrapped and then
something happened with gse game world
the developers and then it was kind of
in this limbo and then it was sort of
cancelled and then now it's a completely
different thing
so to just see something from stalker 2
to know that it's real to know that it's
making progress it's kind of a big deal
so
and for me like gse gameworld is
one of those devs who i mean just based
off the stalker games it's like
they do some wild mechanical stuff in
their games it's not just
oh here's like a post-apocalyptic
shooter with some rpg elements nah
like the the last horrible stalker and
then all of its expansions are
pretty they they they do some they do
some
very detailed mechanical things with its
gameplay
and uh it's very janky in many ways but
almost i want to say it's part of the
charm uh so
i mean i would expect stalker 2 to be a
little bit more polished in that regard
of course it's been
10 13 years since we got call of pripyat
and clear sky and all that so this is
going to be
probably going to be a very different
thing but uh stalker has a lot of
potential that
i think you know the metro series kind
of filled that gap
with 2033 last night and most recently
metro exodus
i loved the metro games a lot but they
they weren't necessarily
they weren't going for that rpg element
that sort of open world element
exodus did a little bit of that but
something about stalker where
almost anything goes and it feels so
dangerous that's the thing about
stalkers that you feel like you can
you can die or get radiation at any
point and it had a very strong horror
aspect to it
uh that 23 like metro sort of did
but there is very terrifying elements
to stalker that are very unique to that
to that franchise so
uh yeah i'm hyped up for this one man
i forgot to mention so all these uh
future games including stalker 2
are world premiere console launch
exclusive so they may come
to playstation a later date um so we
also had warhammer 40k dark tied
uh coming to 2021 series x and pc um
this next one i wasn't really expecting
at all tetris effect
uh it's also getting multiplayer i
remember when that
when that um trailer started and there
was just like
everyone just in there playing on the
series x and then there was one guy with
a tetris suit and i was like
um what's going on um
is this a game and honestly like tetris
effect is absolutely fantastic and then
when the music kicked in i was like oh
damn
yeah i'm going to play this game again
tim you're going to revisit tetris
oh absolutely tetris effect is
incredible like it's
such a good game i was thinking about
playing it earlier uh later on today so
i'm excited for a new version of the
game um
especially one that has like multiplayer
in it um that was always something that
the
tetris effect original was a theme that
it was harkening on that feeling of
being connected you know
the song says it all but at the same
time the the
kind of um persistent world stuff where
you know players would work towards
completing
things together and reaching scores and
meditation stuff and that kind of
business
and now they have the ability to
actually play together that is
massive and they nailed like they're one
of the few companies um
developers to actually do a unique
interesting and distinct take on tetris
outside of like 99
um this is this is one of the best
tetris games in a long long time
so i'm so excited to see that more of it
is coming they've said that we're
reworking
some of the single player stuff and the
campaign stuff and then
adding a whole bunch of multiplayer
stuff well up for it very excited
we also saw a game called the gunk which
is i think
the best titled game i've ever
heard of reminded me a little bit of
i don't know like luigi's mansion
meets i don't even know what
blink's the time sweeper
yo this is this is a spiritual successor
yeah maybe yeah i mean
i just love the fact that they've gone
with the gunk as their title
i think that's the one thing that i'm
really fixating on right now
but i'm trying to figure out what this
game is
is it kind of like an okami type thing
where you're removing the
evil influence from the world and nature
back um
definitely looks like that it looks like
it's got a bit of like
exploration kind of figure out i hope
that it's got like the kind of
um it looks like you're just clearing
the world which is a really simple
but effective way to format a game uh
it's given me vague recall vibes which
is
which is like upsetting but um
but i think i think like the studio the
team it looks like it's in
already in a much better place than
recall was when it really released but
i love the idea of having this weird
world and just going around as this kid
and
vacuuming up all the gunk
and finding new stuff check out yeah big
suck
michael yeah i'm i
was like of course i want to see more
but you know
a lot of these uh i guess i wouldn't say
smaller games because i feel like that's
reductive but
yeah like like we said about uh rounding
it out with the story based games such
as tell me why and then
uh it was as dust falls and then the
gunk which is sort of this light-hearted
uh
game where he's sucking things up uh
yo uh look i i'm a big fan of blinks of
time sweeper i would prefer to play as
blinks
uh no matter what i want to be a a
vacuuming cat that's wonderful i wish
sushi could be out here vacuuming our
apartment but uh
such as the world but you know i i wanna
try i wanna try something new
record if if it's like that you know
record would had some cool things going
on it was just
a very incomplete state i guess when it
uh
when it was launched but that's a
completely different story but yeah
hey the gunk suck up that gunk
all right relax i'm on timeout sorry
it's two days too early
all right let's talk about it so this
next one is my
most anticipated game from the xbox
showcase the medium so we saw some of it
uh was it playstation
no it was the it was the last um xbox
showcase yeah yes
yeah you've got you can rent a little
bit uh
we saw a little bit and at the time i
remember because michael you'd
interviewed them i believe
and they said that they had a gameplay
mechanic that they couldn't talk about
but it was cool as [ __ ] and we finally
got
it today and confirmed it is cool as
[ __ ] it
is um the it's kind of like the
crack in the slab effect and cause
uh titanfall such dishonored missions
where you have these two levels rendered
at the exact same time but the two
levels
it's the same level but two different
states and
honestly i you know i remember
interviewing arcane about
cracking the slab back in 2016 because i
thought that was just such a brilliant
concept for a level
and it looks it feels like the medium
has definitely taken so much inspiration
from that
and having these two states um
looks like a horror i mean it looks kind
of horrible and like it's gonna mess
with your mind i'm
so into it i'm genuinely very very
excited for this one um michael
now that you now that you've uh seen
what the reveal is
do you think it lived up to that hype
about how cool the uh
the gameplay mechanic was uh it
depends on how they're gonna execute it
of course but conceptually
the the story is that you're an
investigator and
of course like in that in that sort of
narrative narrative sequence that you
saw
her talking about oh there's there's
always like two sides to a story or
whatever so the fact that it's going to
be
a gameplay element in this style of
simultaneous rendering
like seamlessly i am excited about that
uh because of this
is um it's one of those things where
okay now the tech is also leading
creativity
in a way and you know who knows how it's
going to be executed but
someone's got to do it first uh so and
of course like
like cracking the slab was wildly
impressive really cool dishonored level
uh effective cause and titanfall 2 was a
really cool level but those were
contained levels
now we're having a full game that's
built around that concept that
i assume is going to be throughout
prevalent throughout the game
and uh yeah it's it's going to be a
horror game as well so it's going to be
very scary and i i want to see how it
actually
uh comes out and plays this is from
bluebird team it's two so
they have a history of doing these
horror style games with blair witch
and then observer before that so they
have done a lot of creative things too
and this is another step in terms of
trying to do something
new in the horror space so um yeah this
is this is gonna be cool and also akira
yamaoka from
the silent hill soundtracks he's going
to be doing the soundtrack as well so
uh yeah if they're trying to evoke some
of that silent hill
vibe in this then hey sign me up
yeah i mean the thing that's probably
key for me is how
you go between these two states
um crack in the slab they had to take
all your powers away from you
as a way to kind of mitigate any of the
randomness that might break the level
uh affecting cause while technically it
was incredible it was you know it's a
first person shooter you don't really
have any other variables
um to kind of deal with there so i'm
very very interested to see how you go
between the two worlds it looks super
cool
i'm very excited to see more about it uh
next up we had
pso2 uh which michael you played a lot
of
um
online uh i'm out here gaming man uh
i was i was hyped just to have fantasy
star online to
come to the west this is a game that was
out in japan since 2012
and then it just released this year for
it just got localized this year and
launched and it is a 2012
ass game uh even even
almost like more dated than that uh so i
was excited to play pso2 but then when
it
when push came to shove and i actually
spent a lot of time in it like okay this
is a dated game
i don't necessarily i'm glad that it's
that it's here that it's out in the west
but
man i'm having a tough time trying to
not just get my head around it but
enjoy the things that it does have
because it has a ton of content
and it has a lot of things to offer i
just wasn't
in the mood to play something that dated
now this
new genesis pso2 is looking like
they are trying to usher in pso2 into
a new generation because i feel like you
can't really
support pso2 in its current state with
more content
you have to overhaul a lot of aspects of
it and
having played pso2 and how slim and
contained those environments are
we're also limiting factors so if this
trailer is showing us anything about the
state
of the game is going to be once new
genesis comes out much bigger
environments
overhauled ui oh man i'm excited about
an overhaul dui because
boy that ui was tough to navigate
so there's th those are at least from
the trailer those are two elements that
pso2 definitely needs to address
that look like they're going to be
addressed with new genesis when it's
coming in 2021 so
i'm going to i respect pso2 as much as i
may not and
have enjoyed my time i respect the hell
out of it so i'm definitely going to
give it another shot once this comes out
uh to see if it can uh can hook me this
time around so
yeah uh
so penultimate game was crossfire x uh
the campaign
which is being done by remedy games
crossfire i don't really have that much
of a
frame of knowledge for um as far as i'm
aware it's you know huge in china
uh but tam you know i know you're a big
remedy fan too
their involvement is definitely got me a
little more interested in this one
yeah same um i think the
the tricky thing here is like uh the
remedy has to adhere to
what crossfire is aesthetically um and
and kind of like make it recognizable to
the people who
play crossfire or no crossfire or even
care about cross or even the people who
you know made crossfire
so i don't think we get a lot of that
remedy flare in
the visual style but i think what we do
get is like we get a couple shots that
look
really really nice and like artfully
done but it's all in the context of a
fairly like generic looking militaristic
shooter
i think what is exciting about this is
it's remedy doing
their own single-player campaign which
is one of the few things that isn't
included in game pass as part of the
crossfire x
um kind of a package but it does mean
that um
remedy gets to tell their own story
within this world
and i we know all know that remedy is
capable of telling
really memorable really interesting
stories and often it does it using
frameworks and genres that you think you
know pretty well
so maybe i'm giving remedy too much
credit having said that
they have definitely earned it but what
looks like a generic looking first
person shooter
could in the hands of the right studio
be turned into a really
interesting and kind of
thought-provoking
or at least memorable story and if any
studio is capable of doing that it's
remedy um
so at the moment i'm kind of keeping my
eyes open
and keep my keeping them on the game and
seeing what it has to offer
so i'm excited to check out more if only
because it's remedy
definitely uh and finally to end though
um we didn't get perfect dark but we did
get fable so we had a nice cdi trailer
narrated by stephen fry
very much had that fable sense of humor
in there there's not really much else to
be gleaned from it unfortunately like
there's no
real indication of size i don't even
think a release date was ever really
mentioned if i'm correct in thinking um
but you know it's just nice to know that
it exists and that playground
are the team that's working on it i know
we spoke about it in the pre-show but
michael
final thoughts on halo um fable
uh fable infinite that is what we we got
over here now i'm just kidding what
uh i don't know like you said it's it's
just it's dope to know that it's
actually a thing
uh it it reminds me of like the skate
four announcements like hey we got skate
so y'all can
stop asking about it it's like okay here
with a playground and xbox like oh we
got fable now you can stop
asking if it's really a real thing but i
mean
speculation again at this point as to
what what it can be
i'm just excited that that they're
they're the fables back
and it seems like it's going to be back
in a way that's
you know not some kind of strange
spin-off thing like that that connect
thing that they had i mean not that
kinect is a real thing anymore for
uh xbox but like a something that really
channels what fable
was probably trying to do all the way
back when it first released
so i think that i would say that
expectations are gonna be high
uh just because uh this is the the new
fable game after how many years
uh you know but i'm we're going to keep
our eyes on it of course so
and it's one of those games that who
knows when it comes but
whenever that is i guess we'll be there
for
for
the hype uh whatever so i mean i'll take
bets on
we'll start a pool what comes out first
skate four or fable or
star field i don't know who knows
oh okay okay hey i'll hold you to that
how much we want that i mean like
fable fable is like one of the worst
kept
secrets not only in the gaming world but
like the specifically the uk development
scene like the the whispers of
a a uk a british studio making a fable
game have been going on for
it feels like years now and then like
when it was
started to you know kind of rumors being
its playground
those were on for a long time this game
has been in development for
what what feels like a really long time
i feel like this is going to get its own
kind of like time in the spotlight which
is why we got what we got today this
kind of like just
enough of a teaser that shows the tone
is where it needs to be
and show off like oh there's a big big
world out there for you to explore
i feel like the next time we see fable
is going to be a big old deep dive into
it
and i feel like it's pretty far along in
terms of development
and comparatively to the other games
that you mentioned there
oh tam with the scoops i appreciate that
uh if we're going for predictions on
what's going to be first i agree i think
it's fable
skate then starfield no
i feel
um so how do we feel about today's
showing from microsoft
i think overall i mean it catered to a
lot of different
uh markets a little a lot of different
fan groups i'm excited definitely about
the medium
um as well i i want to see more from
halo
more from fable overall i'm not as
hyped as the playstation one but i think
that was purely because playstation had
so much from arcane
and i unashamedly really love arcane and
you know death loop is
the game for me so i'm
i also thought representation wise
it was really nice to see more women um
[Music]
on a stage like this and having those
moments to shine
um sarah bond is an unsung hero that
people don't really talk about a lot but
i think she's also she's really great
and i'd love to see her on stage
well on the on the showcase um
overall i think it was a it was a very
solid showing for xbox
nothing really like jumped out of me
or really really surprised me um but i
think that's good i think they're
focusing on you know 4k
uh 60 frames and pushing that but i
think as well
i mean the real the real thing for xbox
is game pass and the fact that we're
hammering home that all of these games
are going to be available in game pass i
think with the exception of what
crossfire's campaign
which is unbelievable it is i've said it
before and i will continue to say it it
is the best deal in gaming um and
game pass ultimate uh you know getting
to play all those on your pc and getting
your xbox live thrown in at the same
time
an unbelievable deal and honestly
it yeah it's the best subscription that
i pay for
i easily um so i think overall
a good solid showing from microsoft
today i
just now i think now i'm at the stage
where
both of them have played a hand the next
hand that everyone has to play
is release date and price because i
can't have another one of these
showcases just seeing games i need to
know what
i need to know how much money to be
putting aside uh time audio final
thoughts
yeah i mean i think the trouble not the
trouble but like i think it was going to
be a rough time for
microsoft personally because sony
announced demon souls remake and
the only thing that would have kind of
really stood up to that is if they
showed it oden ring which they did not
and
i'll be surprised if we see that game
for a while having said that this is not
a contest
all of these games like as someone who
plays games regardless of platform
this is an exciting a really good in
really good like exciting
showcase for them they showed off halo i
want to see more of halo
i want to see like halo mechanically and
in terms of gameplay really hit the nail
on the head for me from based on what i
saw
visually i feel like it still has a lot
to offer if you look at it in
screenshots it's
a bit and i didn't see what was like
like the other games in the showcase
like what was how was the true power of
the xbox
shown there and we got some really great
draw distance and scale stuff but
i want to see more of that game i'm glad
that it looks like it's going to play
just the way that i wanted to and then
they had that really good showcase of
you know
a bunch of uh other alternative
experiences that aren't just shooters
like you said the medium looks amazing
and then you know
forza looks like one of those games
where i probably won't play it for long
but i'll definitely get it
um just to see what the xbox series x is
capable of
and then we ended on a on a on a fable
game
which you know like i said i feel like
we're gonna get a bigger uh
look at soon but a lot of variety a lot
of
exciting things to look forward to if
you're a xbox fan
and a lot of it like you said available
to you as
on on game pass as a subscription
service which
like lucy said the best deal in gaming
so
i feel real good about buying an xbox
series x
at launch um so i think that's the my
biggest takeaway before this i was like
yep
easy playstation 5. now i'm like i think
i'm gonna have to get both because
there's too much good stuff on xbox as
well
definitely michael yeah hey game passes
op
like tam said too much good stuff game
passes the amp i'm a video games out
here
but uh yeah the things uh what i'll say
is that
i mean the hype factor height factor
doesn't really
matter to me all that much uh the things
that we or that i was most hyped about
were pretty like uh i guess slim reveals
which is fine because
uh just the fact that uh we know that
there's a
fable game in the works uh and we saw
something out of it the fact that
stalker 2 is making progress those are
those are exciting things and the fact
that you know we
got to see a little bit about uh what
obsidian is doing
beyond uh grounded and outer worlds dlc
with avowed
those are those are cool things that
they were like short maybe 30 second
reveals but you know i'm i'm fine with
that
to know that that is in the future and
then
the thing i'll say about halo infinite
is that i'm going to play that game no
matter what
i was a little surprised by how relaxed
that showcase was which i guess speaks
to
the sort of game that they're going for
i mean there were a bunch of firefights
and stuff but it wasn't this bombastic
like here's chief whooping ass uh or
anything like that it was kind of like
okay here's a little bit of the open
world here's uh some of the new
mechanics here's that grappling hook
and then here's the the banished dude
who's going to be the villain giving a
monologue so
i mean i'm i'm fine with that and
there's like like y'all was saying
there's a lot of good variety in terms
of
what uh xbox is going to be offering and
i think that that's more important than
hype really
is showing off games like tell me why
and uh
some more narrative based stuff or the
gunk which seems to be uh
more lighthearted and a very different
thing hey i'm out here for the gunk you
know what i'm saying
uh so you know overall it's it's uh it's
a solid
solid showcase and uh i play on pc so i
don't know if a series x is for me but
the fact that you know
again wrapping it up to game pass the
fact that most
if not all of these things are going to
be on pc uh is you know
i'm we out here gaming you know what i'm
saying
coverage and gunk relax
all right get a place that's adding me
to end today's post show thank you so
much for watching we'll be back again
the next time
xbox do uh one of those showcases which
they said they're gonna be doing
throughout the end of the year uh
there's gonna be a ubisoft one
in september probably the show off more
from assassin's creed and i assume
the sony playstation are also gonna be
having one please lads
and lasses i need a release date i need
pricing
information give me it thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
peace out spencer's pecks
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you